i've got a question for you though what
do you think about the whole new simp
movement
that just started in the western like
the western sphere
i'm like why do you guys feel when
somebody call you simp
like it's just even like out of it i
if i say anything positive at all like
oh good job
they'll be like wow you're a simp
connoisseur but you just said a nice
thing to a woman
i feel like the term sim has just been
used so much that nobody even knows what
the original meaning
of the word simp was sometimes writing
it's just like calling your name kind of
thing so yeah
my like mod uh on twitch like had to ban
the terms
i was gonna ask because i'm sure i never
saw the word simp in your chat
they're very protecting they're
protective of me yeah it's because
everyone in the chat is
noticed that they're just like we all
know why we're here
we're all simply for karma yeah yeah i
just like yeah
i just don't understand that term
anymore i mean you know
the internet does what the internet does
best and completely destroys the meaning
of a word
the moment it goes means because now
it's like if you give a female
any attention you're simping like we're
probably thinking you right now
yeah just by talking to you guys you're
going to meet a lot of things
in the comment section
they get a woman as a guest they're so
hard you know
now that we just like blacklisted all
the incognito comments yeah every
comment now is just going to be sim
comments now obviously
yeah i don't know if it's just a joke
thing like we can laugh about it or like
you do feel like
uncomfortable actually like getting cold
oh i mean
i mean it's it's we were clowns we're
just part of the joke
i think the only people who are
uncomfortable with being called a simp
are actual sims
you know what i mean they're just like
how dare you call me out
yeah when the terms sick and good
t-h-i are thick
i was like i saw it was mauritius
maybe negative term for a second because
it's sick you know
so i saw it's just another term for fat
so
but if it ends with a k then it's
malicious if it ends with a c then it's
complementary
it means your body first i didn't know
that
they were commenting like oh you're very
sick how
again like that's another example right
the word thick
is used so much now that i see guys
calling
girls thick that aren't thick they're
not thick at all it's like
it's like you have skin oh that's thick
i can't see your rib cage damn you're
thick it's like no
there's a difference between thick and
just being healthy
yeah so it's like it's like cringe as
well
the word queen oh i hate the word cringe
so much
like because at first again like cringe
actually meant something yeah
people didn't like it but then everybody
just started to be like oh that's cringe
that's cream that's crazy remember
people be like uh
whenever someone made a jokes people
would be like oh that's pretty cringe
but i laughed and i'm just like
are you trying to compliment me i i
don't get it was that a compliment or an
inside i
literally don't know anything that's
like the biggest oxymoron yeah
it's cringe but i laughed on my say that
again but slowly
so as a non-native speaker at first i
didn't know it was like a badass
thing you know kind of yeah it says s
but it's a good term you know yeah yeah
it's not good you just have to learn